GRANT: Hey cloud developers.
My name is Grant.
VINNY: And my name is Vinny.
GRANT: And we're here
to get you started
using Google Cloud Functions.
Google Cloud Functions makes
it easy to run and scale
your code in the cloud that
listens and responds to events.
VINNY: The Functions
Framework lets
you write lightweight functions
that run in many environments,
including Cloud Functions,
your local development
machine, Cloud Run
and Cloud Run on GKE,
and Knative-based environments.
The library is open
source on GitHub.
And the Functions Framework
is used in the production
by Google Cloud Functions.
So Grant, what is the
Functions Framework?
GRANT: The Functions
Framework defines an interface
for building modular services.
This means that
rather than emulating
how your function will
run in production,
you can see exactly how your
code will perform when testing
it on your local machine.
The Functions Framework
is also Knativ-compatible,
supporting Knative
eventing, which
makes it possible to port
your functions between Knative
environments.
Specifically, the
Functions Framework
defines a port for
specifying HTTP functions,
a target name for the function,
and then lastly, a signature
type, either an HTTP or
event, for the type of event.
VINNY: The Functions Framework
can be used in two ways,
either as a CLI, a Command
Line Script, that you
run in your terminal to
start the function server,
useful for local testing, or
as a library, a dependency
for your application.
This is useful for staging
a production Google Cloud
Functions environment
on your machine.
You can specify an
explicit dependency
on a version of the
Functions framework.
And if you don't
specify a version,
Google Cloud Functions will
automatically choose the latest
Functions Framework.
Now let's look at that
open-source framework for Node.
It's used in production for
Google Cloud Functions running
Node 10.
Within the package, the
module uses Express.
Express is a fast,
unopinionated, minimalistic web
framework for Node.js that makes
developing services a breeze.
It's a project of the
Node.js Foundation,
and it's used by the
Functions framework.
GRANT: Let's get started
with the Functions
framework for Node.js.
Let's first run the command npm
install @google cloud/functions
framework.
This will create a package.json
in your current directory.
Create an index.js file
with the following contents.
So what are we doing here?
Well, we're exporting a
function called Hello, World.
The function accepts
two parameters, req,
for the express request
object, and res,
for the express response object.
Next, we're sending the string,
Hello, World, in the response.
To start the server, run
the following command--
npx @google
cloud/functions framework.
Open localhost in your
browser, and see Hello, World.
Awesome.
VINNY: So you your function
running on your computer,
but how do you get it running in
production, like in a real URL?
GRANT: Good point, Vinny.
Since the Functions Framework
is the same library that
runs Google Cloud Functions,
we can deploy our same Node
application with
no modifications.
So let's deploy the code
to Google Cloud Functions.
Using gcloud in our
directory with our function,
we can call gcloud
functions deploy,
specifying our function name--
trigger with HTTP--
and using Node 10.
After a bit, we'll
get a live URL.
If I copy the URL and paste
it into my web browser,
I'll invoke my function.
But where did our
console.log statements go?
Vinny?
VINNY: Well, on my machine, I'll
see the logs in the terminal
where I ran the function.
But in the cloud, I'll
see them on Stackdriver.
This is because
Google Cloud Functions
has an integration
with Stackdriver where
logs written to standard
out or standard error
will appear directly
in Cloud Console.
GRANT: And that's like Google
Cloud Functions Framework.
To learn more about the
Functions Framework,
check it out on GitHub.
We have so many
useful guides on how
to do things like how to deploy
the Cloud Run using TypeScript,
using the Node
Debugger, et cetera.
The link to the GitHub repo
is in the description below.
VINNY: And be sure to subscribe
right here on the Google Cloud
Platform channel on YouTube
to get notified of new videos
about Cloud Functions we'll
see you here next time.